hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
The Walking Dead we totally got to meet
the governor 2.0 as well as Woodsboro
2.0 or tents burry as I like to think of
it let's talk about our top five WTF
moments and then I'll do my review
number five the new Walker aquarium so
the governor has a lake now if you
remember in season three he had that
Walker aquarium which is bitey heads now
he has a whole lake which he christened
with peak number four the family picnic
so Lily's starts to ask questions about
Bryan's past because she knows that
Martinez knew him back then they
exchanged some really uncomfortable
glances but it really makes you think
what's going to happen was the
governor's new family finds out about
woods burry best-case scenario they'll
probably just leave him worst case
scenario
Tara tries to kill him number three the
cabin so the governor Pete and Mitch all
stumble upon this cabin where a man
basically tried to protect his family on
his own they had four walls supplies but
they still were not able to do it he was
still not able to protect his family so
the governor really has some problems
internally and tries to figure out what
he's going to have to do is he going to
have to be governor 2.0 or it can t be
this Brian person and still protect his
family there was also a nice nod to the
Walker aquarium again with a closet full
of Walker heads
number two the governor finds the prison
so if you saw in that scene when he was
in the camper at night it was really
dark and kind of hard to see but if you
look closely you could see he was
plotting a path to the prison just like
me shown had been plotting a path back
to woods burry what this is really
foreshadowing is the mid-season finale
it's gonna be tense burry versus the
prison but the governor makes it really
clear there's a better place out there
if we're willing to fight for it
obviously he's talking about the prison
and that's seen when he was just staring
at me Sean and Herschel through the
woods and he just brings his gun up
obviously the episode just cuts to black
at that moment and it kind of implies
that he might shoot her I don't think
that's the case I think it's just meant
to imply the impending war these going
to wage against the prison and my number
one WTF moment of the episode the
governor killing Martinez and then
dragging him into the Walker pit so not
only was this an intense death scene for
Martinez this was basically like the
moment where the governor snapped or
Brian snapped and he became governor 2.0
or at least made the decision to move
along
path in reality I don't think he
actually became governor 2.0 until he
killed Pete and he put that bad guy
jacket on but in this moment when he's
saying I don't want it what he's really
saying is that I don't want to be
governor 2.0 and realizing that that's
not possible
realizing that he has to be governor 2.0
that's why it seems like he's crying
while he's doing this because he is a
little bit sad because he's basically
can't be Brian anymore
in a way it was almost like season 3
governor was actually pushing season 4
governor into that Walker pit during the
episode he just comes to this
realization that nobody else can protect
his family the way he can but it's
really not about doing the right thing
it's about doing the only thing next
week it is all-out war be sure to
subscribe to get my video for that it is
going to be an amazing that season
finale but overall I really like the
episode it was a nice follow-up to last
week's more cerebral episode obviously
it's mostly just setting up what's going
to be happening next week so this was
kind of a break in the action even
though there were some really intense
scenes this was the episode where Brian
basically decided to be the governor
again right now in The Walking Dead I
really do feel like he is the most
interesting character on the show that's
mostly just due to the fact that he gets
so many more scenes than all the other
characters but it's also david morrissey
who's just an amazing actor I know that
the Walking Dead spin-off show that's
going to be happening after the final
season is gonna be about a different
group of people in a different City but
I feel like you could just do a show
about the governor but let me know in
the comments do you think that the
governor is the main character of
Walking Dead more so than Rick and let
me know what was your favorite WTF
moment from the episode since there are
so many shows that are going on break
this week for Thanksgiving I'll probably
do a bunch of bonus videos for each of
the things that I do I'll try and get a
Thanksgiving themed Walking Dead video
out to Walker gobblers and all be sure
to subscribe to get everything and right
now click here to get last week's
Walking Dead video and click here to
learn all about the Doctor Who Christmas
special I just did a breakdown to the
trailer and it's gonna be awesome thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives
you